no matter how much I make up the stuff
in history that's just as bad or worse
the words of celebrated author world
builder and favorite character murderer
george RR martin now martin has really
admitted that some of the most famous
events from A Song of Ice and Fire and
it's TV adaptation Game of Thrones came
from infamous events in British history
so let's go back and find out which ones
here's six times Game of Thrones stole
from history there's book and show
spoilers ahead so be warned the
long-running Civil War between the
northern house Stark and the rich
southern House Lannister is pretty much
a direct parallel of the Wars of the
Roses from 400 years ago due to a blip
in the line of succession there ended up
being 2 families vying for the throne
the York's and the Lancaster's they even
sound like stark in Lannister there was
a lot of lingering resentment and
scrambling for the throne from both
sides the marriage between Henry the
sixth and Margaret of Anjou was a
political one to secure peace with
France and it's mirrored in Robert
Baratheon's marriage to Cersei Lannister
they married to secure an alliance
between their two Great Houses after
usurping the Mad King Aerys Targaryen
Henry the sixth was prone to bouts of
severe mental illness meaning he was
unable to rule the country
his power-hungry and ruthless wife
Margaret often ruled in his stead kind
of like Cersei their son Edward had some
startling similarities to Joffrey just
like jock Edwards true parentage was
often questioned and it's widely
believed that he was the product of an
affair that Margaret had with one of her
supporters just like how pretty much
everyone in Westeros knew that Jaime was
actually Joffrey's dad but that's not
where the similarities end at the tender
age of 13 edward apparently talked of
nothing but cutting off heads and often
attacked his young friends with a
variety of weapons sounds familiar right
there was also a Ned Stark in the
equation protector of the realm Richard
of York was Henry's best friend and
Margaret absent
he hated him and managed to get him
packed off to Ireland when he dared to
disagree with how they were ruling the
country Richard of York's son Edward
would also pull a Rob stark by backing
out of an arranged marriage only to
marry someone else
luckily for Edward though he didn't end
up like Rob did and while we're talking
about character similarities how's about
Robert Baratheon and Henry p8 in their
youth both were renowned fighters who
had the love of the ladies but as they
settled down and took wives they each
gain weight became fans of the drink and
were less than faithful to the old
ball-and-chain
they both left the ruling of their
kingdoms to other people
Robert almost never attended the small
council meetings and Henry was much the
same he preferred to let his Privy
Council take care of matters while he
spent his time hunting which is of
course another favorite pastime that he
and Robert shared admittedly though
Robert didn't have half as many wives as
Henry did been sitting here for days
start the damn joust before I piss
myself
the wall is a giant structure that
stretches across the northern border to
protect the Seven Kingdoms from the
threat of wildlings and the others that
reside beyond its inspiration actually
lies in the north of England Hadrian's
Wall stretches for 73 miles from the
banks of the River Tyne to the solway
firth when it was built it stood three
metres wide and between five and six
metres tall it marked the northernmost
limit of the Roman Empire while we don't
know why it was built in the first place
it's widely assumed to be a defensive
measure against the local northern
tribes who Emperor Hadrian decided would
be too difficult to bring under Roman
control should have persevered Hadrian I
mean John snow managed to get the
wildlings onside Khal Drogo was a great
Dothraki warrior hell bent on conquering
Westeros with his bloodthirsty khalasar
their methods weren't dissimilar to
those of the Mongol hordes led by famed
Emperor Genghis Khan both led armies of
fearsome mounted warriors who raped
pillaged and murdered their way through
anything that stood in their way but the
similarities don't end there
you may recall the grisly end of Viserys
Targaryen who had a vat of molten gold
poured over his head well it's not
dissimilar to how the governor of atre
met his maker after royally pissing off
genghis khan by killing a whole load of
his men khan had the governor executed
by pouring molten silver into his eyes
and mouth and you thought that pizza
burn was bad
season threes red wedding is one of the
most infamous events in Westeros in one
fell swoop Tywin Lannister Walder Frey
and Roose Bolton managed to take a whole
bunch of thorns out from their side in
particular the upstart King in the north
Robb Stark Walder Frey's treachery was
all the worse because he broke guessed
right an ancient custom that once
invoked guaranteed that neither host nor
guests could harm each other for the
duration that the guest was staying such
hospitality laws actually existed and
Martin has spoken in the past about how
he took inspiration from two specific
events the black dinner and the Glencoe
massacre the black dinner involved the
murder of the 16 year old Earl of
Douglas and his younger brother the
brothers were invited to dine with the
10 year old King James ii of scotland
but it was all a trick and during dinner
a black bull's head a symbol of death
was brought in and placed upon the table
the brothers were then taken outside and
promptly executed the Glencoe massacre
of 1692 had a much larger body count
clan Campbell were guests a rival clan
MacDonald and putting their differences
aside
they brought soldiers and stayed under
the roof of their enemy for ten days and
nights clan Campbell accepted the
hospitality of the MacDonald's but one
night the Campbells arose and murdered
almost 40 members of plan MacDonald as
they slept houses were set on fire and
those who tried to flee into the
mountain
eventually ended up dying from exposure
to the elements
now this last one's technically cheating
because it's from a piece of plastic
literature and not directly from history
but Wald afraid being served his sons
Lothar and Walder in a pie is straight
out of Shakespeare's Titus Andronicus
after the rape of his daughter Lavinia
the eponymous Titus cuts the throats of
the rapists drains their blood into a
basin grind their bones to powder and
bakes their heads after that he serves
their mother tomorrow a pie made up out
of her dead son's so while there's no
face switching in this one it's still
equally as grim so there we are
six times Game of Thrones took
inspiration from history any I've missed
let me know in the comments below or
come find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy
James games for more on Game of Thrones
and make sure you head over to
youtube.com slash GameSpot all men must
subscribe
you